hello everyone I don't know about you
but I'm very excited about garry
kasparov playing the st. Louis rapid and
with tournament in August and so I
thought it'd be nice to check out some
of his previous games for example I
chose this game it was played in 1994 in
the info chess Express challenge in
Munich Germany
Gary Kasparov is black and is playing
white against the Vladimir Kramnik and I
just wanted to say that although casparo
inspiring Karpov were approximately of
equal strength during their championship
matches because para was always a little
better but this game illustrates nicely
white as part of the games are much more
enjoyable to watch as he favors activity
above all so let's look at the game like
I said chronic is white in Casper is
black so we have d4 Knight to f6 c4 g6
Knight to c3 Bishop to g7 efore d6 not
to f3 cuz power of castles Bishop to e2
e5 d5s power plays a5 Bishop to g5 h6
Bishop to h4 and so far this is all
theory all the moves are by the book so
crimeny goes OH curse power goes 92-86
Crimea castles Bishop to d7 Knights to
d2 and cause power plays Knight to c5
and with this mode Kasparov prepares an
idea I'm sure that was prepared before
the game and cronic plays b3 like
nothing is happening and this is the
idea of the position
you can see that this night after white
played the b3 this night is now
undefended and this is how power of uses
this idea
he plays Knight captures on e4 and
allows White's to capture his queen so
chronic captures the Queen Bishop takes
on d8 because part of captures on c3
attacking whites Queen Queen to e1 and
the rook captures on d8 picking up the
bishop as well and in this position
well although black does have some
activity white is actually better and
but chronic was obviously very upset
about this sacrifice and he played the
rope to see one it's very hard to
understand why he would give up this a
two point but gari grabbed it
immediately so nightcaps resonate to he
goes back to Europe to a 1 and now Gauri
plays Knight to b4 and well okay this
white rook now has a semi-open line but
is it really worth it I don't know
so we have Bishop to d1 protecting that
ball or pawn on v3 and now II for
opening up a discovered attack from the
bishop to this work on a1 Kramnik plays
rook to b1 and gar replace rook to e8
protecting this efore pawn so Queen to
b3 and now f5 and now if you look at
this position okay
Black's lost the Queen but who would you
rather play here who would you prefer
black or white so we have h 4 rook to s8
are preparing to push f4 so Kramnik
stops at he plays g3 and now rook to d8
a rupee eight and if you look at this
position all the black's pieces are
placed very nicely this light square
bishop is still waiting for some
activity but you'll see gari will solve
that as well so King to g2 Knight B goes
to D 3 R up to G 1 and now f4 and now
look at this bishop slicing slicing this
diagonal here and this dragon slicing
all the way to here so crimeny captures
G captures on x4 rook captures on f4 and
r h5 gari closes it with g5 we have rook
to f1 and now rook the age for trying to
read that H pawn so kramnik replace or
up to h1
gari goes back rook to at for Cromley
goes back up to f1 and now Gary finds
another idea rook to f8 so we have F 3
root 2 H 4
now the
born isn't offended by the light squared
bishop anymore so chronic catchers F
captures on e4 Knight to f4 check King
to g1 Knights to d3 d5 Knight captures
on e5 rope to c1 and now because part of
a deck of the Queen rook to h3 and we
have nice to f3 we have g4 pinning the
night so kramnik decided to capture on
e5 and to give up his Queen as well but
you'll see after rook captures and e3
Knight captures on d7 and nice to h3
check although the position well both
players have the same amount of pieces
but well Gauri has the initiative so we
have Kings to g1 the King has to go to
g1 if it goes to h1 it will be over
quickly
we have rook captures on f1 King
captures on f1 and now g3 and well black
is a lot better in this position but
chronic plays King to g2 and it's over
immediately after Knight to f4 we have
King to f1 although in this position
chronic resigned but after King to f1
well you would get this G to check move
and after King to f2 you'll get a rope
to h3 and this is unstoppable because
Bishop to g4 check is coming so a very
nice game goodbye Kasparov and I really
enjoyed how he sacrificed the Queen
unmoved 12 to get this extreme activity
although chronic could have played
better and not give up his a to bond but
it's very hard you know we were playing
against Kasparov he just sacrificed the
Queen and well it's not that easy to
keep calm at a moment like that so I
hope you enjoyed this game and as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here and if any of you are Game of
Thrones fans I'm interested to know what
you thought of the first episode I still
haven't watched it because I'm waiting
for my girl
to come home from work so we can watch
together and yeah that's it
too soon